من فوليدار الى سوليدار هو حرف واحد يتغير
ومعه طبعا تتغير النتائج في الاولى روسيا
تعاني كما ذكرنا في الثانيه بسطت سيطرتها
لكن قبل هذه السيطره استفادت اوكرانيا عبر
ملح سوليدار الذي بات جزءا من تمويل
المجهود الحربي فيابت القوات الروسيه
سيطرت على المدينه في يناير الماضي الا ان
الملح المستخرج من مناجمها يستخدم الان
لشراء طائرات مسيره نائب رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني للابتكارات والعلوم ميخائيل
فيدروف اعلن انه سيتم شراء اكثر من 2200
مسيره كميكازي لاستهداف القوات الروسيه
اشار المسؤول الاوكراني الى جمع ما يقرب
من مليون و600 الف دولار عبر منصه خاصه
انشات لجمع التبرعات داخل اوكرانيا هذه
المنصه مشاهدينا اعتمدت على بيع مئه الف
عبوه من الملح من مدينه سوليدار تم بيع
الواحده منها مقابل 13 دولارا و56 سانتا
نائب رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني اشار في وقت
سابق الى ان ثلاث شركات اوكرانيه جديده
مدعومه بتبرعات خاصه ستعمل على صنع طائرات
مسيره لاستخدامها في استهداف القوات
الروسيه المسيرات لعبت دورا مهما كما
تعلمون لكل من اوكرانيا وروسيا في هذه
الحرب